did you plan to be a filmmaker
i always loved movies uh so i i never
thought one day that i was gonna make
movies until that that happened in
college
uh but i i was always obsessed with
movies
and um you know my brother and i would
go like when i was a kid and suburban
chicago like movies were like 350.
so i would go to movies all the time we
would sneak into the rated movies all
the time because you could
um and we just saw everything under the
sun um
and it was like a big deal um so you
know this is the time that we would wait
for hours and hours and hours for star
wars to open or the indiana jones movies
to open
and you know i would be in line for like
two and a half three hours
um waiting and the lines would wrap
around the theater and
so i didn't plan to be but it was always
a
passion and obsession of mine since i
was a kid
when did it become something you had to
do i took an
incredible class in college
it was called the american documentary
tradition
the professor showed us pretty much the
entire canon of classic american
documentary films we started with nanook
of the north
we moved into penny baker and the maisel
brothers and barbara koppel
uh rob epstein and jeffrey friedman um
really all of the major documentarians
of the day we watched all those films
and then we would sit around and we
would talk about them
often really um emotionally
or you know some you'd they'd be crying
there'd be
you know a lot of debate and um i was
really
uh my eyes really were open to what
film could do the power of film to
generate those kinds of reactions in
people really knocked me out
so that's when i got the idea that this
is actually something that people do
um this is a profession and and that's
when i started to pursue it
really after that college class what do
you get from filmmaking that you don't
get
from anything else um i think
i think to be a filmmaker you have to
have an in
sort of an innate curiosity about humans
you have to want to know about people
um you have to want to know about all
the different
shades that are inside of them the light
the dark everything in between
you have to really love people because
it's not a solitary
pursuit it's a communal effort it's
collaborative
so it's a combination of being curious
about people and also really enjoying
being around people i mean unless you're
making little stop animation films in
your garage which is totally cool when
you're by yourself
you're going to be with people and so
filmmaking is this incredible
opportunity to learn about the world
through
the eyes of other other humans and also
to create these incredible little micro
communities um
who are your collaborators you know your
your writers your cinematographers your
producers your
production designers your everybody that
you get to work with it's like this
each film is this opportunity to be a
little mini mini family
um it can also be a mini disaster you
know
or a big disaster depending um so it's
just this incredible opportunity to
learn a lot about yourself
by being around other people you know
who are kind of on this sort of common
goal
you're all on this ship together i'm
trying to get to this
place um in the service of a story
yeah i think it was it francis ford
coppola and i use this quote a lot but
nothing
invites chaos like passion and you know
just so so
yeah like you're saying it could be a
wonderful experience or there can be a
lot of things that
yeah can happen because it's it's high
stakes pressure
yeah to make your day if it's you know
i'm sure with documentaries it's
different but
i think it's not any different with
documentaries i mean i think people like
to
think that there's documentaries and
there's
narrative cinema and that they're that
they're
completely different lanes of filmmaking
but there's so
much that's the same it's still story
it's still character
you still have to engage people um in
the most exciting situations they're
both for a big screen
so you have to think about how you're
capturing the images and
what you're you know the only difference
really is that with documentary it's
unpredictable
you don't know what people are going to
say you don't know what they're going to
do um in scripted for the most part you
are controlling all that
so there's a thrill to it um but i think
all the same things that i learned in
narrative filmmaking i applied to
documentary filmmaking
a lot of my favorite filmmakers are
filmmakers that
have their hands deep in documentary as
well scorsese spike lee
bennett miller people who go out and
make films you know
about the world and real people and then
go off and make incredible narratives as
well
um and i think a lot of the tools that
you learn as a documentarian
are very similar if not the same uh
that you that you need as a scripted
filmmaker it's story i mean really
everything is in service of the story
um the only difference is that in
documentary it's life it's true it's
real
and you're in service of sort of doing
the best job to bring that
to light but you still at some some
point have to craft
where it's going and even if it's
showing you
you have to sort of paint you know for
the audience perspective within that two
hour
absolutely i mean you're still using the
same tools you're still
you're still using editing music you're
still deciding about composition and
lighting and
you're still using incredible cameras
that we have at our disposal right now
um uh graphics and animation all kinds
of stuff
um i think what's really exciting time
to be a documentary filmmaker because
those toolkits are expanding you know
people's ideas about documentaries are
like
really really expanding now so you're
seeing films that are
um that you wouldn't have seen back in
kind of the earlier eras of documentary
the documentary used to be more kind of
like frederick wiseman like you go in
you show up at a big hospital or an
institution you turn on your camera and
you let life
unfold i mean now they become
a lot different a lot more cinematic a
lot more
i'd say engaging in some ways like
sherman's march
yeah from years ago and and maybe to see
it today it would seem slow i still love
that film yeah and i love his little
like
sort of talking to the camera and almost
like a precursor to some reality tv
where you have people doing these
confessionals but a
much different feeling from it yeah
definitely i don't think you would have
uh um a morgan spurlock if you hadn't
had
sherman's march that's true you know
right yeah
i was listening to an interview with
john pilger he's a journalist
and someone in the audience yelled out
at a q a you know
there's this issue you know and went on
and on what are you doing about it
because he covers various issues in his
films and he said well why do i have to
be the poster child of
of having to do something about it we
can all do something
about it nowadays how do you feel about
that because it used to be a select
group
that would be able to spotlight these
stories and go and delve in
and now all of that's anyone anyone
sort of with their own agenda or their
own need to tell a story and a camera or
a phone
can do that what are your thoughts i
think
um i think ultimately
what i'm what i'm getting from the
question is uh it's kind of a larger
a larger issue about like um the ability
to get
stories out there right i mean we all
have twitter
right twitter's a storytelling device
um in x number of characters or less um
all of these device all of these apps
are are our newfangled stories and we're
all kind of technically our own little
filmmaker
i don't think that's the same as
making a film there's a responsibility
in making a film if you're making a film
about something that's true if you're
making a film about something that's
about
real life or if you're even making a
scripted film about something that's
historical fiction
you know you have a responsibility as
the filmmakers
to do justice to that story otherwise
you're going to slip
into the propaganda universe and just be
filling the world
with more of that and i think filmmakers
are bold
and they're on the frontier they're
truth
seekers i think that's true of even the
best
scripted filmmakers you know i mean i
think back to boys don't cry
you know and what kimberly pierce did
you know that was
an incredibly powerful eye-opening
experience that the world hadn't seen
before
um and she did tremendous justice to
that i think we you know
that's i like that your site is called
film courage
because that's the kind of courage that
that it takes to be a filmmaker you have
to be willing to really
tell the truth and not be sort of just
agenda pushing all day long
because people see right through that
and by the way it's you know unless
you're the president of the united
states
whose agenda pushing all day long you
know you're you know you're most likely
kind of in your own little echo chamber
and you have to be prepared to take the
punches that are going to come
online or in written form from people
that have various agendas whether they
really didn't like the film
or they're a paid troll which is
something that
i guess has been around for ages but now
we have a real name for it
yeah and yeah there's just all sorts of
people in the peanut gallery that have
an opinion yeah yeah i mean the thing
that's so great about um
filmmaking period right now is we all
have access to these tools that we
didn't have before
you know you can have a phenomenal
camera
in your hand you can have a phenomenal
editing device on your laptop
you know when i started out it's like
you couldn't do that
no you had to go and you know wait by
the av cage in your high school or
your college and hope you got a camera
then you had to take a camera out you
had to put
film in the camera when i started you
know what i mean and then you know
and then you know film became these
tapes that we lugged around i mean
we have you know kids can make films
these days
so it's an incredible time to be a
filmmaker and now it's the question
really is okay so what are you gonna
make a film about
when you feel that someone's got to make
a film about this story
why do you feel you need to answer the
call i think it's a very personal thing
it's very subjective
for me i'll be listening to
public radio for example or i'll be
reading an article
and i'll get a feeling i'll get a hit um
sometimes that hit will be outrage
sometimes it'll be compassion
sadness uh humor it'll hit me on an
emotional level
um and then i'll have a thought um
is this a story that could be a film and
then the next thought is um
okay so if this is a story that could be
a film this is a story that
that i should tell that i'm able to tell
or i'm interested in telling
and then it kind of just goes from there
um
i i think that there's a lot of
important questions we have to ask
ourselves you know um
a very wise friend of mine um a fellow
filmmaker
once said to me you know there's there's
basically three basic questions
um why this story why now
why you
and you know you ask yourself those
three questions and then it kind of
helps you like gives you a little bit of
a gps
by the way i'll say like and that's not
to say that like i was born to make a
story about
a supermarket tabloid like i never read
the inquirer growing up i never cared
about supermarket tabloids i thought it
was a joke
to be honest with you um the the other
sort of
important thing about documentaries is
access
so this story found me in a way because
a parent of one of our dear friends
was in town and we all went out and had
drinks and he starts
you know rattling off these crazy
stories about his former life as a
tablet reporter for the national
enquirer and i was like wow this is
unbelievable you know i could listen to
this guy all day long
so so i knew i had a window into that
world
you know before that dinner i had no
idea i didn't know i knew anyone at the
enquirer
so i think access is a huge part of
filmmaking
documentary filmmaking is you know it's
one thing to have a great idea
but i think how you get into that idea
that's a huge part of it and that that
that can make your life
um easier as
a documentary so leaving that
family event or that that dinner event
whatever
at what point did you start thinking in
your mind i
i have to tell this story you know i'd
say about
you know we had that dinner
he told us all these crazy stories about
espionage and recording people and
disguises and like you know booking
hotel rooms next to madonna and sean
penn and just crazy stuff
and i thought okay this is an incredible
movie um and then at the same time
jeffrey toobin wrote an article in the
new yorker
about the relationship between donald
trump and david pecker in the national
enquirer
and that's when it started to percolate
oh this is actually a bigger film
you know and so that's when we i i
called my friend's father and i said hey
do you think you could get other
of your former colleagues to talk on
camera about their experiences as
inquirer reporters and he said well let
me work on it
and that process took many months and
some people refused my phone calls
some people slammed the phone down on us
some people
said i'll consider it and never got back
some people said i'd love to but i have
a non-disclosure agreement and i'm not
going to violate that because i don't
want to get sued
they were scared but enough of them said
why not
i'll do it i don't have a contract
anymore i don't have an nda
um i don't you know this is a story that
should be told
let's do it um and that's when we knew
we had a film and with all that
information with that access
that's when we went to the folks at cnn
films and said hey
we have something here and during those
many months
that sort of all this was coming
together and you were getting yes's nose
maybe
were you also going to the supermarket
and watching people interact with the
paper
absolutely i mean that happened before
that so starting in
late 2015 2016 as the campaign was
ramping up
uh i would have these very bizarre
sensations in the supermarket line
looking at the tablet headlines
because there were these really weird
stories about
you know hillary clinton going to jail
she's hooked on narcotics
she has six months to live um
apparently every week she had six months
to live um and then you know all these
glowing stories about donald trump and
how he's gonna make america great again
and
yada yada and i was like this is crazy
this is the national enquirer and i feel
like i'm looking at a
political poster in my face you know
with my cereal
in line at the grocery store so i just
started to feel like this is crazy
and then you start reading reports in
other
places about this kind of
uh these strange bedfellows between the
trump campaign
and ami and david pecker and that's when
it all started to kind of
pique enough curiosity to make us pursue
a film
what was the peak circulation with the
national enquirer and
what is it today so in 1977 the national
enquirer had done something that it
had never done before it it put a
photograph of a dead celebrity
in his casket on the front page and that
celebrity happened to be elvis presley
it was a an unauthorized photograph they
got it
by sneaking somebody into the
receiving line you know as they were
going past the casket somebody had a
hidden camera under a necktie and
snapped a shot of dead elvis and that
issue
sold nearly seven million copies and it
was the
highest selling tabloid in the history
of the world nothing had sold more than
that
and that was the peak um you have to
understand that if seven million copies
are being purchased that means that
almost 25 million americans were reading
that which was astounding in 1977
because for every epis
every issue of the inquirer of three
americans read it you know the mom would
buy it come home
then the husband would pick it up and
then somebody else in the household
would pick it up
and then that's not to mention all the
people that would sort of talk about it
in the beauty salon or the barber shop
or the
you know auto body repair or the grocery
line so
it was really this like early form of
social media viral social media
um before we had these devices we had
you know
we had these tabloids and then its low
point i would say is now
right now circulation is under 200 000
um which is one of the lowest
in its in its history if not the lowest
people just aren't buying it
the way that they used to in the grocery
stores because they can get all their
information
by just going like that for free um
what's unusual about the inquirer today
is that those racks those supermarket
racks that
the founder of the inquirer acquired
back in the early 70s are still there
today
so the the location of the paper is the
same
and now what you have on the paper
rather than elizabeth taylor or burt
reynolds or liberace
is political messaging that's what makes
it so powerful today
because how many how many hundreds of
millions of americans go to the grocery
store every week that's the one thing
that hasn't changed over the past 40
years we're still going to the grocery
store
and you're sitting there you're waiting
in line the lines haven't changed
and you've got to look at these images
whether you like it or not it's having
an effect on you
so it's not so much a certain story that
stopped the circulation it's just more
how we consume news
it's just what happened to american
media culture i mean the inquirer became
a current affair in hardcopy
and entertainment tonight which became
huffpo and tmz and buzzfeed which became
twitter or facebook and then twitter so
you know
the largest tablet in the world right
now is twitter
and what we have is the most powerful
publisher
of a supermarket tabloid sits in the
oval office
he just releases episode after you know
issue after issue of the paper
every i don't know how many sec how many
few seconds does he tweet
each time he does that's essentially a
tablet if you read them
the headlines feel like tabloids the
language it's just ripped straight from
the pages of the inquirer
so that's what the inquiry has become
the inquirer is twitter now
did anyone try to talk you out of making
this film my accountant
okay aside from your accountant no
okay no no one said don't don't go down
this rabbit hole don't
the opposite okay the opposite you know
it's like some things are
um kind of self-evident
you know i think for me i'm interested
in subjects that are
relevant to our world that are happening
now that have an impact on
on all of us um so i was
seeing this having a tremendous impact
plus i'm really interested in the way
that the media
impacts our lives i've always been
really fascinated with that
do you think you could have worked for
the national enquirer say 1980s 1990s
it's so funny when the film premiered in
la a few weeks ago
a couple of these enquirer reporters
were there on stage with
me and uh one of them leaned over and
said you know mark would have made an
amazing enquiry reporter
and uh amy nicholson who was our
moderator linda and she said
so mark would you have would you have
been interested in being an inquiry
reporter and the answer is no um
i wouldn't have i think that it's a real
faustian bargain to take that job
you are trading a lot
of your own ethics really for that job
uh i like aspects of what they did i
i i really believe in holding truth to
power i really believe
that um people who
do things that are unethical who are in
the public eye
should should be exposed i think that i
don't have any problem with that
so some of the things they did i think
were great in terms of that
certainly the reporting they did in the
oj case the john edwards
situation those were things that i think
were
in the realm of uh i'd say good
good reporting but for the most part
it's just been i think something that
has helped
degrade journalism and erode
the public's understanding of what is a
fact and what is not a fact and that's
dangerous
so no i wouldn't have been interested in
being a part of that
had you heard the term catch and kill
before before we started the film
actually working on the film in earnest
i hadn't heard the term catch and kill
because the first time i heard the term
catch and kill was when i read ronan
farrow's article
uh it was april of 2018
uh about karen mcdougall and that was
when
um that was the first time that i'd
heard about it that's the first time
that i think it started to get
introduced
into the news media in a big way
um in making the film before that like
we were shooting before that all came
out
um which was wild that was kind of
freakish that we were out
in the world filming the enquirer and
then this big revelation called catch
and kill happens that the timing of that
was really unusual
but what we were learning on the field
from these old-time inquiry reporters
were like no we never heard of the word
catching kill the term catching kill
before
we always called it trade outs like okay
we have some really sketchy information
about this celebrity
you know bob hope for example and uh
so we're gonna present that information
to mr hope's team
his publicist his lawyer his agent
whatever it is
and then in exchange for not running
that story
he's gonna tr they're gonna trade out
for a story
about uh christmas at home with the
hopes or
a ride on the golf course um with you
know and they did this for
all of the major celebrities so you know
you can imagine how much dirt
they acquired decade after decade of
doing that kind of a practice
but they called it trade outs they
didn't call it catch and kill catch and
kill
was something that i first heard of
through rowan and pharaoh's reporting
and then there were also by the way his
book is fantastic oh okay yeah and then
you have him in the film as well uh
briefly
yeah archival footage and then there
were also where they would
purchase the rights to a story and sit
on it
was that like another form of catch and
kill in a sense because then
that story sort of was taken out of the
hands of that individual
yeah that happened in in a number of
instances and in the film there's
there's a number of anecdotes
that that go into that and that's a very
disturbing practice
because a celebrity has been caught in
the act of doing something really
heinous and
oftentimes it was celebrities who would
go on to do things much worse
down the line and so you have to wonder
had those stories come to light back
then
and not been buried with the what the
behavior that happened later have
happened
and that's that's where i think the
story gets really chilling
does the public have a right to know
everything about celebrities in your
opinion after having done this film you
know there's like
several camps on that some people think
once you get into the public eye
your life your secrets are no longer
your own the public
owns you in some sense i don't believe
that
i don't believe that i mean you know why
should that be the case
i i i think that a lot of a lot of
gossip reporters a lot of tablet
reporters use that i think to go to
sleep at night
and look at themselves in the mirror but
i don't believe that just because
somebody is entertaining us
um uh or compelling us with a great
performance
or you know engaging us with incredible
music
or whatever it is that they're doing
that we're entitled to know everything
about them
i think that that's um
i just don't think that that's right um
and i think that
uh the truth is is that it's a business
and that um there are benefits that
celebrities and creative professionals
artists musicians
get from being in tabloids they get
publicity they are
they get to promote films people buy
into their image
they buy into the narrative um
but i think this kind of ruthless
pursuit of people
um you know hounding them with paparazzi
hounding their children um i don't i
don't see the point
i think that's just more about a
sickness in our culture
you know this obsession with wanting to
know everything about other people this
comparison
compare and despair you know um and
that's that's
that's a larger issue well one part that
was
especially chilling in the film for me
was when one of the reporters or maybe
two talked about how it was actual
family members not not just disgruntled
employees
of a celebrity or a politician that
called in tips but actually like
family members and supposed friends and
it was really based on jealousy
i was just that was that was sort of
like a real gut reaction
and and just i don't know what are your
thoughts on that i guess you've already
i was fascinated with how many people
would sell
would sell people out you know that was
people ask me like what's the
what are some of the most interesting
things that you discovered in making the
film
um one of the most interesting things
was the length to which these inquiry
reporters would go to get sources
around famous people so like nurses who
were checking people into hospitals
valets uh maitre d's at restaurants
waiters at restaurants
barbers beauticians but also close
family members
you know disgruntled lovers the sister
that is not that's the black sheep of
the family a child
whatever it is um all these people were
on the inquirer payroll
so you know i don't think it's any
different today
um but it is pretty chilling when you
realize that you know you get famous you
get rich you get powerful
and there is a price to pay for that and
that you will become susceptible to
people
selling you out was there one thing that
was just a huge eye-opener for you
in doing this film and going i think you
know what's so it's so interesting the
i think the the the number of people
involved in um
gathering negative stories are up about
the rich the famous and the powerful
and then um brokering those stories
to curry favor or whatever they're doing
whatever reason it is why they would
take a
negative story and keep it and then um
uh you know that that network
was really eye-opening the fact that
that exists and not just in the enquirer
on a much broader level you know
somebody in our film says
you know that there are thousands of
these deals made every day
to protect the rich and powerful
that's that's pretty eye-opening that's
a very sobering thought
you know that if you have money um and
you're in a position of power
in the country in the culture that you
can use those resources
to maintain a bright and shiny image and
i think making this film
made all of us very aware of just how
often that happens
sure wasn't it orson welles who had
numerous things that were
thrown at him for the movie that he did
from a powerful family that wanted to
silence him
yeah a powerful family in the news
business right yeah you know you make a
film like that naturally there's going
to be backlash
i think there was someone who warned him
like don't go to that hotel room there's
there's a story waiting to happen there
you know so yeah it's happened since
the guy from touch of evil is in that
hotel room don't go in there
why do you think we're drawn to these
papers even though
we can flip through them in the
supermarket line and think well that's
fake
yeah that's embellished that's not a
real photo but what is it in us as
humans that we're drawn to this oh my
god
um i i don't know the answer to that
question i think that would take
probably uh
an anthropologist to answer that
question
somebody really understand i mean i
think this is fundamental human nature
like this goes back to shakespeare and
the greeks and the romans before that
and actually you can even probably take
it back to like the cave paintings of
pompeii where it's like the
the sexual acts of the rich and famous
were displayed for all to see
you know i think this is part of human
nature where
we're drawn to the lurid
we're drawn to the um the
seemingly unattainable we're drawn to
the um salacious
i think it's you know jung would talk
about this i think this is like this is
the shadow side
um and i think we're seeing now that
while it's no different from cave
painting times we just have so many more
outlets for it
that it's everywhere you look you know
our culture is kind of it's kind of like
consumed the culture
in a way this obsession and uh you know
it's not going back in the bottle
well you talked about in the film that
generoso pope the
the founder of the enquirer had said
that the ideal reader was was it missy
smith in kansas
yeah and it was this you know good
suburban housewife
you know probably who knows went to
church on sunday i'm i'm adding that
part but
and then there was a part of her that
just enjoyed sitting down at the end of
the week
reading through this and knowing that
these celebrities or these different
people were just like her in some ways
do you think that reader has changed the
person who's consuming this has changed
i don't i don't think she's changed i
think that general sopope was
really uh kind of a marketing genius
to have identified the ideal inquiry
reader
back in the late 60s and early 70s and
to really understand
almost everything about her you know he
understood
what she would want to talk about with
her girlfriends at the beauty parlor
she understood what she would want to
show to her husband when she got home
and she also he also understood what her
husband would want to read
he called it a hey martha he would pick
up the inquiry would read about another
ufo invasion in roswell
and he would yell across the hall hey
martha you got to read this this is you
know there's a
three-headed alien that landed in
roswell
so you know he he understood all that
and i don't think that that has changed
so much i think what the inquirer did
really well was
blend all these different stories into
one publication so that the reader kind
of in
a way was convinced that they were
getting things that were good for them
miracle cures fad diets all that kind of
stuff
stuff that like piqued their their
curiosity of the supernatural
you know a madonna that has you know
cries blood
you know um uh a talking dog you know
pigeons that communicate with each other
um all that all kinds of stuff
um and then all of the celebrity stuff
that people have been obsessed with
forever um
so he created that perfect formula i
don't think that formula has changed
um and i think everyone who has bought
the inquirer
since and controlled the inquiry since
has understood that
i'd say the difference now is that the
the current you know
in the trump era you know the people who
ran the powers that be who ran the
inquirer
recognized that missy smith in kansas
city who was the ideal inquirer reader
was also
a voter and had political
power and rather than feed her miracle
cures
and fad diets and what lonnie anderson
and
reynolds were doing they were feeding
her political propaganda
that's much more dangerous when do you
think that changed with like the reagan
era i
remember seeing a lot of the reagans on
on the front of the enquirer
never negatively no i mean you know
maybe there was a story about
ron or maybe there was a story about
patty you know going off the rails or
something like that but
they were not super regular features the
inquirer did not
really touch politics until gary hart
and that's really when it happened
when they realized that a politician
could be as scathing and scandalous as
as
the most scathing and scandalous
celebrity so
do you think americans realized that the
national enquirer helped
to elect donald trump you know i don't
have the ability to answer that question
accurately
i don't know what the americans american
voters thought
i know that he was elected
and i know that a major supermarket
tabloid
dedicated a tremendous amount of its
front page
space for months and months and months
to that effort
so the only thing that i can surmise is
that
and also endorsed a political a
presidential candidate for the first
time in its entire history
they'd never endorsed the inquirer had
never endorsed any presidential
candidate before donald trump
so you know the writing's on the wall it
doesn't take i think a rocket scientist
to figure
out that they were very much in bed with
the trump campaign
and had a major stake
in doing whatever they could to get him
elected
measuring how successful that was i
don't know how you do that
but um the film was an attempt to kind
of connect the dots and say well how in
the world did we get here
how do we get here because we hear so
much about facebook
and sort of these people whether you
know from whatever country
trying to influence and and show
different things that will pull
emotional triggers and things like that
and so
we're looking to facebook to sort of
point fingers and say well
that's what happened and that's helped
to sway people and their vote
but something that was so innocent
seemingly innocent which is right there
as we're getting our
groceries and we may not even purchase
it but we still pick up on those
headlines it's still sort of
imprinted i just wondered many people it
seems like i hadn't really talked about
it or maybe i just didn't see that until
watching your film
the the effect that that could have had
well you know
so there's an incredible media
watcher named brook gladstone she's a
public radio
reporter and she has an incredible
podcast program called on the media she
also wrote a book called the influencing
machine
which is one of the greatest books i
feel like it should be required reading
in high school for
everyone to really understand what the
media is in our culture
because ultimately this is about media
literacy
like do you understand when you're
standing in the grocery line looking at
the national enquirer
that you're looking at a paper that is
propaganda or
do you assume that it's a piece of
journalism
that's held to the same standards that
other
papers and outlets are
you know so i think we're it's on
us you know everybody likes to point
fingers oh it's it's facebook's fault
it's
it's inquirer's fault it's the new york
times fault it's cnn's fault it's fox as
yeah i mean of course you know fox is a
propaganda machine
there's it's it's if you don't know that
and you're watching it thinking that
it's real news
perhaps you need to sort of educate
yourself on what real news is
um because it's not real news um it's
propaganda but there's propaganda all
over the place there's biases all over
the place
um so i think you know for us right now
it's on it's on us it's on every person
every american really
um to pay attention to
where they're getting their sources from
you know
you know you look you watch what you eat
so you might as well
watch what you consume in terms of media
well i love democracy now and the
intercept but i don't see it
at the checkout counter it's not the
headlines aren't there
yeah i have to go on my computer to look
at it yeah so this is so
in your face whether you dismiss it as
trash or
you think it's real journalism it's
still there it's still shouting a
message
yes yeah i mean i think that that's
really powerful
especially because it's it's there you
know an
an issue of the enquirer is on the
newsstands
for what seven to ten days so
that's you know think about how much
money a political
campaign would have to spend to to
create a poster and put it in a place
like that for that amount of time
you know that's a lot and and this is
free sean
you know trump campaign didn't pay the
inquirer to do this it's free
advertising
once you felt you had this green light
to go ahead or you felt you'd have
access
to these journalists how was this
setting up the interviews what was that
process like
um tough it was tough
because we didn't you know
some people said yes and it was easy and
we were able to kind of make
times and places and meet them and
others
uh led us along for quite a while and
you know to the really down to the wire
day of
kind of stuff so we had to really um
be patient and just let things play
themselves out
you know tabloid reporters are very
smart people
and shrewd and want to kind of know
what uh what you're up to um
and uh so gaining people's trust and
saying look
this is an opportunity for you to have a
space to tell it
like it was for you um rather than me
imposing all my ideas about what it was
on you
or trying to frame you in a certain way
so that took a minute to get people
comfortable um and then it was just
about like finding these locations
and that was really i had an incredible
producer named jennifer ash rudik
who had access to all these beautiful
places um
in the various cities that we were
filming in and i have a tremendous
partner in my cinematographer michael
pessa who
just has an incredible eye and the
ability to just make
really anything look epic um and that's
what we wanted to do you know we wanted
to find these locations that were a
little bit over the top
because the inquirer is over the top and
you know chasing people around and
trying to get these crazy stories is an
over-the-top
career so we found all these great
um houses and private clubs and
restaurants and bars and things in new
york and palm beach
and um and los angeles and
that's where we we situated these people
sometimes they were their own homes but
most of the time it was these locations
that we found
it was almost as if you were in the same
shoes as
the reporter because it seems like they
went through a lot of cat and mouse
with people as well yeah leading them
along oh definitely
you there was a lot of phone time
and and emails and back and forths and
kind of
you know um but for some
and for others it was like yes of course
i'd love to
do this this would be great i um
no one's ever asked me to tell my story
before so let's do it
i'd say that was a good number of them
and then there were a couple of like
really hard liners that kind of dug in
their heels
for a while i thought it was interesting
to see some of them that
expressed some of them said they didn't
really feel that bad
about some of the things that happened
and others said that they felt it wasn't
a high point in their career and i just
thought it was interesting to
see the human side of what's behind this
paper yeah
the sort of the people doing the
groundwork and
yeah that was a huge um one of the
reasons why we wanted to make the film
was to
get into the minds of these people these
these
tablet reporters and to kind of figure
out what would make somebody want to
take a job like this
um and you know
the film really goes into that the film
really looks at okay so what was this
career like
what were the what were the perks and
what were the downsides of it
and that was really fascinating and the
stories that were
killed even though the reporters went
and got them oh yeah and
a lot of these reporters did amazing
jobs getting the stories but then
getting the stories printed was a whole
other thing
that wasn't up to them that was up to
the editors and ultimately up to the
people on top
you know it's not a comfortable movie
it's not
made to make you comfortable it's a
it's it's a film that's going to
agitate you and hopefully get you
thinking
um so if if it does that
it's great if it alienates some people
and they think that and it pisses them
off
great great that's why we're making
films
we're not making films to sedate people
and or make them super comfortable or
serve up for them exactly what they need
you know there's other
there's other things out in the culture
that are doing that you know the purpose
of a documentary film or really any film
i don't think is to be an opiate
i think it's to be like some smelling
salts you know
sometimes people don't like what they're
waking up to it's not our problem
were there parts of the story that you
wish you'd followed up on more closely
were there things that you didn't get
were there things that
you felt you left out or maybe you
shouldn't have put in
i think i'll tackle the first one
because that really resonates yeah i
mean we wish that we could have
dove way deeper into the catch and kill
story
and gotten into really what happened
with karen mcdougall
what happened with stormy daniels like
you know but we realized that if we had
done that
that would have been the entire film and
then we wouldn't have been able to
really answer the first question that
made us make the film which is how the
hell did we get here
we really wanted to create a sort of
like a reverse engineering of how we got
to this crazy moment
where you know women are having their
stories
suppressed for money and
where powerful political figures are
are partnering with powerful media
entities to keep
negative stories out of the public's
attention in order to
rise in the polls and and and
um all of that stuff um we
uh so but we of course i would i would
love to have
gotten an opportunity to have included
karen mcdougall and stephanie clifford
in the film um
you can only do so much you know what i
mean i think that's also that's that's
the challenge too is like when do you
what's the frame around your story
what's the time frame
what are the resources you have to work
with you know 60 years of american pop
culture it was a lot to tackle
so we just had to make choices you know
and do the best we could
once you saw the first cut on the
editing timeline
what were your thoughts what did you
feel that you needed to
tie up or finish or or add or i mean
editing is
arduous and crazy my first thought when
i saw the first cut was my god we got so
much work to do
but i had the incredible opportunity to
work with two amazing editors
andrea lewis and ben dottery and so we
were like a
three-headed monster um and they're
incredibly gifted
editors incredible filmmakers so
everything was put through this
incredible scrutiny you know
times three because we have three heads
in the editing room i mean it's it's
it's amazing to have one editor it's an
incredible gift to have too
and we needed that because we had so
many hundreds of hours of archival to
sift through
and all these stories to tell from the
50s to
the 2000s and just so much work to do
but that allowed us to get really um
really kind of intense and tight with
our storytelling um
so the first cut you know i mean i think
most of us
who make films are kind of cringing at
the first time
sure but um yeah but
what it is though at the first cut it's
like it's a it's a benchmark
you get there and and it's and it's a
great moment
because you know that you've got
something to work with
you know it goes from like total
amorphousness to
something and aside from
obtaining the interviews um was getting
clearance on the archival footage the
the second most sort of time-consuming
thing oh without a doubt
without a doubt um got to work with an
amazing archive producer named um
aileen silverstone she's worked with
jordan peele on the lorena bobbitt
project she's she's really um i'd say
she's kind of like the
guru of archive and she was amazing to
work with
and we um but it was it's it's a lot of
that is just like needle and haystack
kind of stuff especially if you're
looking for archive that the public
hasn't
seen before a lot of archive most people
are familiar with you know there are
classic shots of
especially with celebrities and stuff
like that so finding
the rare archive that was that was
really challenging and then
uh figuring out whether or not we could
afford that uh we ended up fair using a
lot of stuff which was
a godsend because that saved a
tremendous amount of money from the
budget
um and fair use i think is a real
filmmaker's gift
um to be able to know that you're
actually entitled to use certain things
depending on how you use them gratis
and that that was um that was amazing
for us
in a certain time period yeah all that
yeah i mean there's very strict rules
and you have to spend money to
hire a really responsible law firm to go
through and vet
literally every single shot every frame
it's very arduous process
but you ultimately end up being able to
use material
that can make your film and that's what
we
that's what we did we had so much
powerful archival footage
one that stuck out to me and maybe this
has been around and i just hadn't seen
it before
was the george clooney sort of yeah
proclaiming to the
the crowd what what an invasion of
privacy and how damaging this is and
yeah um you know you don't really think
about that you just think i want to know
about george clooney and his love life
but then to see him as a human
and you can see it on his face that it
is damaging and we don't know
everything that's been said and how much
is true and how much isn't but just the
fact that it's
a human and their life is there for all
of us to
pick apart it was very powerful yeah
that that piece of archive is incredible
yeah yeah all the archive around the
princess diana
tragedy that that we found i thought was
was pretty amazing much of it i hadn't
seen like i hadn't seen
shots of her and her children in
on ski slopes before and the press just
trying to just
constantly invade her life like that you
just realized that she just had no
she had no privacy and they hounded her
right you know and you could see how
ultimately that resulted in
a tragedy sure and how she handled it
too she was quite polite
i remember the one scene that you had it
was almost i mean it made you
sad at least it did for me it was very
emotional
to see that she didn't she wasn't ugly
about it in that moment when most people
you could see why people would throw
punches or do different things i mean
if this was something that was a daily
occurrence yeah
it was interesting that you showed that
you know it was a very pro-american you
know
support our troops for some of the the
stories and and the political uh
showcasing but if it had been a little
more
um uh trying to think of the word if
if the if it had been less so let less
pro-american do you think that the paper
would have survived
you know i don't know i don't have the
answer yeah i don't know it's it's so
hypothetical i don't i don't know
um you know
generously pope and the editors of the
inquirer
knew their readership they understood
their readership
and their readers were patriotic their
readers were proud to be american
and so they served up to that readership
uh what would appeal to them you know
charlton heston's stories you know all
kinds of
stories stories of the uso
you know that's just
understanding their readership and they
continue to do that
through the years i mean you have
steve kaz who was the former
editor-in-chief for 10 years of the
inquirer really at its kind of
heyday in the 90s in terms of the
stories it was breaking say you know
at our core as you said at the core the
readership was
was was patriotic so you see the content
of the paper reflecting
that i have no idea what the paper would
have been like had it been
otherwise because how would i know sure
yeah
what lessons did you learn from the
national enquirer on storytelling
oh um i think um
that uh what lessons did i learn
from researching the national choir i
learned that
um you can take a story and you can spin
it in all kinds of ways
depending on the way you frame it
depending on
the information you choose to include
the information you choose to exclude
the guys at the inquirer the men and
women the query they were expert at that
they were experts at that
and so what i learned from
working on a film about the inquirer for
a year
is that there's a real art and science
to that
um what i also learned is that
that doesn't serve the truth um
that serves circulation and sales and
you can spin a story
and make it seem like something happened
when it didn't or
make innuendo and really sway public
opinion about
a person or an event one way or another
but that's not telling
the real story so i learned that too
do you think people want to read the
real story
i would hope so i mean why not
i mean but the thing to remember for me
is that the real story is never
from one single outlet it's like you
know
kurosawa made rashman right it's like
any event can be viewed from
seven different perspectives and
everybody's coming with their own biases
and their own
filters about what happened
but there has to be some objective
understanding of what truth is otherwise
we're living in a chaotic world
you know i know i'm sitting here looking
at a a a a human being in front of me
and she's
connect you know we're talking i know
that this is happening right
how do i know that this is happening
there's some sort of an objective
understanding here of truth right so
i would call that a fact you know the
fact that we are having
a debate about what that word means
truly that's really
alarming to me as a filmmaker as a human
as a
parent um you know so
i hope the film at the very least will
get us we'll get people kind of
continuing to talk about that um
because i personally believe that uh we
we do want to know as much of the story
as we possibly can